hello everyone
i'm dr maple hennig i'm a senior
research fellow
uh in the dr anderson and
uh dr linger linger labs at mit
uh so today i wanted to describe some of
the work that we've been doing
developing anti-fibrotic materials
for the use in immunoprotection
of cell-based therapies
uh so a little uh introduction into uh
immuno isolation
devices so what these are and the whole
goal is to protect
therapeutic cells within a
semi-permeable membrane
so they're protected from the immune
system so they can still function to
secrete some sort of therapeutic protein
that can regulate a disease so
a small molecules and things that the
cells need to survive
like oxygen glucose can easily diffuse
in
the cells can produce that therapeutic
protein of interest
which they'll secrete which will diffuse
out of the device
to then affect the response uh to
control the disease
um however um this membrane blocks
entrance
of important immune cells like t cells
uh that would otherwise reject
uh these cells so really what we're
trying to do
is create this living drug factory where
these cells can continuously
continuously produce this drug of choice
so we don't need to repeat injections or
oral doses
and most importantly we won't have to
give immunosuppressive drugs which have
a lot of
negative health risks you're more
susceptible to
blood lymphomas or other types of
infections
and so for these types of devices you
can use multiple
kind of cell types you can use primary
cells that
are isolated from donor organs
you can use cell lines that have been
engineered
to secrete some sort of therapeutic
protein of choice or you can even use
differentiated stem cells
as a solution to this
need for kind of or
shortage of donor organs they can come
in
a variety of shapes so they can be
spherical
like microspheres they can be
encapsulated in planar sheets or
they can even come in these cylindrical
fibers that contain your cells
of choice
so particularly i've been interested
in a beta cell replacement for the
treatment of type 1 diabetes
so on type 1 diabetes these patients
have
an autoimmune response to their beta
cells
which end up ends up destroying these
cells so they can no longer produce
insulin and so the current standard of
care for these
types of patients is they break their
finger they
monitor their blood glucose levels so
either manually inject
the amount of insulin that they're
needed or
there have been advances where you can
get continuous
glucose monitors and even insulin pumps
however it's been very difficult to
fully
recapitulate the dynamic uh kind of
glycemic control that's normally seen in
the body
so normally this is uh blood glucose
homeostasis
is maintained by the islets of langurons
which are
cell clusters that secrete
uh various hormones such as insulin
which will lower blood glucose levels
on glucagon which will raise blood
glucose levels
and then somatostatin and some other
hormones that uh
tight glycemic control
and so the body has evolved and these
eyelet cells have really evolved to
maintain
this tightly regulated blood glucose
levels which you can see
within this narrow range
that is highlighted by the the red
dashed lines
and using a continuous
glucose monitor of patients that have
undergoing
manual insulin injections you can see
but they're often outside of this range
and even when you use an insulin pump
that can try to you know precisely time
when to
inject this insulin they're still often
out of this range
and this is really being outside of
these
ranges is what leads to the long-term
complications and the increased
morbidity
associated with type 1 diabetes and so
i've really been focused on how can we
replace
this cellular control system to really
restore this
physiological glucose control
and so in my previous lab
i worked in a phase three clinical
eyelid transplantation where we would
take
a donor pancreas we would enzymatically
and mechanically digest the organ into
small tissue fragments
we would then isolate the islets and
infuse these
into the liver of type 1 diabetic
patients where they'd become
large and small capillaries and then
these cells would just live
in the patient's livers and so this
was very effective and it would restore
the dynamic and that physiological
blood glucose control we had some
patients that were influent independent
for over 10 years however there are some
drawbacks so
like i said this requires systemic
immunosuppression
and those drawbacks and there's also
a limited number of organs that can
treat all the diabetics
and so i've been working on
kind of a simple method of cell
encapsulation within
algebraic microbes so where the ios can
become
entrapped within these hydrogel spheres
and alginate is nice because it's very
cell friendly and it crosslinks
in the presence of divalent cations to
solidify this gel
around the eyelids
and so this strategy has worked very
well
in many diabetic mouse models
so here this red dash line any blood
glucose level below
this line is within the normal range
signifying that these animals are no
longer diabetic
and these encapsulated islets can really
function for
very long term up to a year in these
mice
and this has led to a small number of
clinical trials
with encapsulated human ios and these
same
kind of alginate based formulations that
were tested in these mice
however the human patients only
experience
transient eyelid graft function and very
little
therapeutic benefit and so one of the
main issues
is that investors investigators reported
clumping of the microcapsules adherence
to a mental tissue
and a strong fibrotic fibrotic response
of these ilo grafts and so in here i can
see this thick layer of
fibrosis surrounding the capsule in this
kind of dense ecm
and cellular network it really restricts
the diffusion of oxygen
and other nutrients that are important
for the cell survival
and ends up killing these islets
so kind of historically people have
debated
um is this an islet problem or is this a
material problem
um so isolated islets can vary in
quality depending on
the isolation process which is very
artisanal
and also just the uh or the organ donor
and like that the quality of
how they happen to pass away and some of
the issues surrounding
the organs
and then another potential cause for
this lack of functions that
this intraperitoneal transplantation
site in the abdominal cavity
uh it's been associated with low oxygen
levels which may not be ideal and maybe
this led to
this graph failure however in certain
romance rodent models
people have shown that there is a
foreign body response
to alginate-based formulations and this
has a consequence negative effect on
iowa graph function and so we wanted to
test this so
we took those same formulations that
were implanted
uh implemented in clinic clinical trials
we formulated them as empty beads so not
including
uh any islets and implanted them into a
higher order
uh animal species a non-human primate uh
that
perhaps is more similar to a human
patient
and so by one week we started to see
cells attached to the surface of the
microbeads and by four weeks these were
completely
uh embedded and in fibrotic tissue
so very uh similar to the reports
with the encapsulated ios
we looked at the different cell
populations that were responding to
these alginate-based formulations and
from cb11b
myeloid foreign body giant cells apple
smooth muscle actin
myofibroblasts and many of the salt
types that are associated with foreign
body responses to implantable materials
so these results really suggested that
the fundamental
problem was material based and not
necessarily with the ios themselves
so a very talented post-doc arturo vegas
at mit was screening
small molecule modifications to the
alginate backbone
to find alginate derivatives that could
inhibit this
fibrosis or this foreign body response
to materials
so of these 800 you found three
different formulations that could
prevent fibrosis and mice
and then these were shipped to chicago
where we could then test these
in the nhp model as we attested
the clinical algebras and so from these
three
formulations we found two that were the
most effective
at reducing fibrosis alginate spheres
so then we wanted to see how this
would protect allogeneic ios
however over the course of these
experiments we observed that we would
transplant these spheres
near the liver and the abdominal cavity
however over time they tend to descend
and settle within the douglas space in
the base of the pelvis
and so we really didn't want to form any
clumps because if you can think that
any cells in the center of these clumps
are going to be super far away from any
blood vessels
and that is going to restrict basically
similar to fibrosis
and lead to loss of viability so we
hypothesized that we could
place the encapsulated islets within
uh the bursa omentalis um so this is
this thin
uh membrane uh that tissue bilayer
basically
uh this hangs like an apron above your
intestines
and so we hypothesize that the friction
of those diesel mental
kind of folds and these tissue layers
will prevent the sedimentation of these
alginate spheres
transplantation technique
so here is a video of the
transplantation
technique so laparoscopically we make a
a small incision
uh in the greater momentum
then our encapsulated iots and spheres
are within a syringe and then they are
infused
um laparoscopically into the bursal
mentalis
and so here you can see that the
encapsulated eyelets
are within that tissue bilayer so it's a
little hard
it's a little hard to see but you can
see maybe like one capsule where
um it kind of goes underneath that fast
fat tissue and it's kind of in between
that that tissue by layer
so then f
so then after four weeks we wanted to
retrieve the ios first to observe
how they look within the intraperitoneal
space
and so we can see that they are well
distributed
within that tissue bilayer in the bursal
mentalis
they're also translucent which is always
a good sign so that
indicates that there's no fibrosis
of these spheres since you can still see
see through the capsules and so
then he also infused a large amount of
saline
and is going to aspirate uh the solution
um shortly and so this was to see
if any of the spheres had leaked out of
this uh
burst elementalist or this um kind of
tissue
uh membrane and so you can see we didn't
find uh any
any spheres um with them um within that
aspirated fluid so then we wanted to
look at the biocompatibility of the
spheres after retrieval
as we found very little fibrosis
in six out of seven of the nhp that were
transplanted
so these are images of inverted
phase contrast so any kind of dark
sphere
indicates that that that sphere was
basically completely covered
with fibrosis however we found that only
occurred in one of the nhp that was
retrieved at four months
then we took these retrieved spheres we
dissociated on these cells
on the surface and quantified the number
of
cd68 cd11d positive
macrophage cells which are important
kind of marker
important cell type that's involved in
the foreign body response to implantable
materials
and we can find a significantly reduced
uh
number of these cells compared to even
a plane alginate
control that contain no allogeneic
eyelets inside
and we estimated the number of viable
cells
per eyelet throughout the course of the
experiment from
pre-encapsulation all the way up to the
four-month
retrieved iowas and we find
that dy115 can protect
viable islets at a similar
comparatively high viability compared to
even before transplantation
then we stained the retrieved islets
with diffizone which is a red dye
that binds to zinc within mature insulin
granules and we can see
bright red staining indicating
mature and grafted mature endocrine
tissue
we then performed a glucose
glucose-stimulated insulin secretion
assay where you
incubate the retrieved ios in a low
glucose solution
for one hour and a high glucose solution
for one hour and we measure the amount
of insulin being secreted into the
supernatant
and we can find a significantly
increased amount of
insulin under high glucose compared to
low glucose
indicating that the iots are maintaining
their glucose responsiveness
um then we used a microfluidic-based
uh paraffusion assay to probe
some of the intracellular coupling
factors that are important
in the insulin secretion pathway
um so using a set of dyes we are able to
monitor
um basically the intracellular calcium
levels and then the mitochondrial
potential which are important um
pathways are in the influence secretion
pathway
so if you look at the center figure
maybe i'll go into detail
about how this pathway works so you have
glucose
come in it gets metabolized by
the mitochondria and converted to atp
this closes potassium ion dependent
or atp dependent potassium ion channels
this leads to a buildup of potassium
ions within
the cell that depolarizes the membrane
then this
opens up voltage dependent
calcium ion channels which causes an
influx
of calcium and then that influx of
calcium
causes mature insulin granules to bind
with the cell membrane for
insulin exocytosis and so here on the
top
right um you can see that once we
stimulate with a high glucose
at five minutes we get a spike of
intracellular calcium levels
that is not significantly different than
pre-transplant levels indicating that
these voltage-dependent
ion channels are intact within the
retrieve iowa
and similarly we see a similar decrease
in the mitochondrial potential in the
creating that
these mitochondria are actively engaging
in glycolysis
and important for in the insulin
succession pathway
so in this study we can show that the
long-term protection of viable and
glucose responses
l-genetic iots was achieved in non-human
primates without any immunosuppression
and from these and some other studies
that we've performed we have found
two small molecules that resist fibrosis
and we can graft these onto a variety of
materials and they have a similar effect
and these results initiated
the formation of a startup company
therapeutics in 2016 and they just have
recently transplanted the first patient
with an encapsulated engineered cell
product
that secretes factor eight for
hemophilia a which is exciting to see
and how material functions in human
patients
so i'd like to thank my advisors
dan and bob my grad school advisor host
jose oberhauser
all the other graduate students students
postdocs technicians
that have helped for these projects
and yeah normally i would take any
questions but i guess
maybe i will tomorrow